welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down it's The Truman
[Music]
Show the movie is now celebrating its
25th anniversary and a brand new 4k Blu
Ray has just released after picking it
up I just had to break down this film as
there's so many deeper layers to it that
I've not seen before it's one of those
movies that was ahead of its time and it
predicted several things about the next
two decades this included the rise of
reality TV and also how much of our
privacy started being put out there all
of it was done in the name of
entertainment which people now do freely
with social media and YouTube so yeah a
lots of things I want to analyze along
with all the hidden details that I think
you might have missed in it this
includes all the hidden cameras like
like that one in his wedding ring on
flashbacks we can see his dad wearing
this during the voyage in which he
apparently drowned and Truman taking
this also explains why he never takes it
off we'll also be talking about hen spot
the clothes in the show being warned by
the viewers and this is because
everything's for sale it's all to make
money and it's all exploiting a human
that a corporation owns and this darker
ideology was laced way more through the
original script with the idea being
created by Andrew nickel originally
titled the Malcolm show the first draft
was more of a science fiction Thriller
set in a city Ain to New York Truman was
an alcoholic and his wife was also
pregnant with his child being the one
that would carry on the show there were
also staged crimes which Truman refused
to intervene in with a casting crew
often questioning why he didn't help in
the end he came face to face with
Kristoff and all the actors who' played
his friends and family lunging at
Kristoff he then tried to strangle him
unleashing the rage that the Revelation
brought we closed out with him being
reunited with Sylvie but it was a far
more downby portrayal of how Carrie
plays it they also went with several
directors as well and Brian the Palmer
was initially in negotiations this fell
through though and then they asked Tim
Burton Sam Ry Terry gilam David
Cronenberg Barry sunell and Steven
Spielberg Before Peter wear finally
signed on deciding on a more lightharted
tone he ended up looking to Jim Carrey
who too was looking to be taken more
seriously as a dramatic actor though the
actor commanded a fear of 20 million at
the time he dropped this down to 12
million to be part of the film his
schedule was also pretty complicated too
with him working on both a cable guy and
Liar Liar we ended up delaying
production for a full year because he
felt that Carrie was perfect for the
role Nicole also rewrote the script 12
times and a lot of inspiration was taken
from Michael Jackson we said the
singer's life had been turned into a
show and that they wanted to document
what it would be like if that was taken
literally depicting the life of Trum men
they settled on that name because he's
the true man in a world full of actors
the surname Burbank was also taken too
because the entire show shot in Burbank
California in fact if you look at all
the names in the film these actually
pull from Real World things Marin's
named after maren Brando and his
offscreen wife's called Rita after Rita
haywith Truman's wife Merill is named
after Merill Street and his upcoming
love interests called Vivian Lee
Truman's dad's called Kirk after Kirk
Douglas and his mom's named Angela after
Angela Lansbury Sylvia's show name is
Lauren Garland with a surname of course
being a reference to Judy these being
actors is well because they're all
actors and the locations in the town
also carry this too Barrymore streets
named after Drew Barrymore and Wells
park is a nod to Aon Wells James Stewart
Street well you know with that with
Lancaster Square being BT Lancaster that
takes us into the film itself and the
movie opens with Kristoff talking about
Truman's appeal and why the world's
become fascinated with him he says that
people became bored with actors in
special effects and that they crave
something real that was actually
authentic inadvertently predicting
reality TV we'd see as this became
something that was a phenomenon in the
ughs even today the shows are still
popular but it's fair to say the
audience has become way more
sophisticated
deep down we know that it's manufactured
too which this movie also somewhat
predicted interestingly Dennis Hopper
was originally in the role of Kristoff
but he walked off after the first day
Jack Nicholson was then off at the part
but he turned it down due to being
friends with hopper they also offered it
to Jonathan price who you might remember
played a similar role in Tomorrow Never
Dies but he was on holiday at the time
so he couldn't get the script cuz this
was back before things were done through
email in the end they settled on Ed
Harris who's actually only 12 years
older than carriers realizing a
12-year-old couldn't be a television
executive that adopted a newborn baby
the makeup Department had a challenge on
their hands however they made Truman
look younger and Kristoff look older by
having things like wire rimed glasses
and dark muted clothing in the end I
really think it works and you totally
believe that Harris is old enough to be
like this the cat's names come in and I
love the way this plays out giving us
the idea that these are real people we
see interviews Talking Heads in the
title card popping up while Truman
nonchalantly talks into a mirror now
this itself contains some symbolism
later on as he gets a bar of soap and
ends up drawing an astronaut in it
astronauts of course leave their world
behind and travel into new ones like
Truman at the end The Mirror's Edge that
also creates a box around him and he's
finally heading out into this different
life now after this we see as he goes
into the street where he greets the
neighbors and drops this line oh and in
case I don't see you good afternoon good
evening and good
night I kind of feel like this was told
to him by someone else and he's just
repeating it as part of his catchphrase
now why this is and it's a theory time
is because the show broadcasts 24/7 so
it would need a universal greeting due
to all the different time zones some
people watching this would be seeing it
at night but this covers all the bases
and means that it works for everyone now
from here he goes out to his neighbor
whose been we can see has a camera on it
later on when he pops up to check Truman
in the car we can see as he positions
this to get a better angle and from this
point a skylight comes crashing down and
we see as Truman goes to check it on the
posts we can also see cameras there too
pting in every direction so there's
always constant coverage now this light
has a really cool detail on it and we
can see that the sticker has the word
Sirius Sirius is actually the name of a
star and this was likely one of the ones
used to light up the dumb sky and the
cover up on this is instantly brought up
where this getting this message over the
car radio just then an aircraft in
trouble began shedding Parts as it flew
over sea Haven just a few moments ago
this is them just doing things to try
and explain what happens so he stays
stuck in this fake reality forever
keeping Truman stuck in the dome is of
course Central to the show's success and
throughout the movie they try several
things to make him scared to leave I
kind of feel this message of a play
might make him scared of getting one and
therefore he never feels like he wants
to leave the island Truman also works in
Insurance andless he's someone who has
to constantly sell something that talks
about danger I'm guessing this would
cause him to be way more fearful and
life as he spends his day talking about
ways people can die either way the radio
itself seems to answer him back showing
that there's this constant Spotlight on
him we hear thisly with classical drive
so why don't you forget about the pearls
of flying settle back and let this music
calm you down and you might notice that
most of the songs in the movie are
classical pieces this is because they're
all public domain and therefore the show
wouldn't have to pay for any of their
usage there is one song we'll talk about
later on that isn't but even this has
been altered in a certain way now from
here we cut to a new stand where we see
Harold buying a paper this character
actually gets a nod later in the movie
when we cut to a collage at Sylvia's we
can see that she's reached out for help
from other cast members including this
news vendor who sadly didn't go through
with it at this point Truman rushes
through the streets which is where he's
stopped by the twins who constantly
appear throughout the film these used to
stall him in front of the kaer chicken
advert and help to add some product
placement to his morning stroll as we
learn the show airs without commercial
IAL interruptions so they have to
integrate the products into every single
scene in the wide shot we can also see a
camera at the top as well and a little
drain underneath the wall now I don't
know you mate but if you know about
construction then you'll know you don't
put a wall up over a drain like this
this would be completely cut off from
the way the pipes are and having a half
drain here shows the building probably
isn't real instead I think they just
stuck up a wall like this so it look
like a real place when in reality it's
probably a fake building and the twins
here were actually on the set security
guards who we watch getting along with
the casting crew in the end he decided
to give them a part and I love how they
kind of bring a sort of surreal feeling
to the movie I've got twins myself but
you know you know what I mean just
seeing them looking exactly alike adds a
feeling of it being almost like like
they're clones or something I know
they're not clones but you get what I'm
saying um now at his office we see
Truman desperately trying to find syia
and he even Cuts eyes out of women's
magazine to try and make a collage of it
I see you like cutting the eyes out of
photos of women
my son is a big fan of that too we also
see as his boss tests him to see if he's
willing to go off irand and turning this
down reassures them that he's not trying
to leave however his heart longs for the
sea which we actually see right next to
his desk name plate to the left we have
a boat and to the right is a lighthouse
which foreshadows the journey that he
makes at the end going out to the ferry
even the dialogue here has used as a way
to play upon his fears of the sea one
way or
return return we also see as the camera
rotates that the blinds open up showing
that they're controlled electronically
by its movement littering the dark with
a sunken bow this causes crippling fear
in him that keeps him stuck on the
island it's such a smart way to keep him
locked in and it's something he has over
come in order to escape from here we cut
to his wife Merill arriving home from
work which is when she drops an advert
which is I think's hilarious look what I
got free at the
checkout it's a chef's pal it's a dicer
grater peeler Allin one never need Shar
sharpening dishwasher safe
wow that's amazing now we can see Truman
also digging in the garden using a trial
to move about the dirt later on when he
digs out the basement we can see this
tool in the hole carrying across from
this exact moment I do kind of wonder if
he was planning this all along and
slowly digging his way out of it you
know sha shank style something about his
life is just so manufactured and you do
wonder if you'd start a suspect just by
how fake it is now there's actually a
medical condition which is known as
Truman syndrome in which people believe
that there's a show built around their
life I'm sure all of us yeah at some
point we've suspected it too and I think
that's why this film just feels so
relatable just something about it kind
of hits home with everyone and it's
obviously steeped in paranoia and
feeling like the world is fake let me
know below if you've experienced it too
and I have to admit I have felt that way
as well then I realized that for about 8
hours a day I sit in a room making
YouTube videos so I don't know how
interesting that would be to watch
anyway from here we get across to Maron
who's about to drop the best ad that
you've ever
[Music]
seen that is a beer later on when he
goes looking for Truman He also leads
with these cans in shots so that we get
the focus solely on them throughout the
movie we often C to the Truman bar which
also happens to sell this exact beer
everything is leading that and like them
we've got some bills to pay too however
they're good ones mate and if you like
these classic movie breakdowns and I've
actually got a deal that I think you're
going to love Us in Aro films we've
started up a partnership where viewers
of this channel get 10% off whether you
want RoboCop 4K the Hellraiser
collection in 4k the Chucky ones or
whatever you want just use my Lincoln
pin comment for 10% off if you forget
then just use the code heavy spoilers at
checkout and M that's a fine deal anyway
Truman talks about leaving his job and
getting off the island and Mullins uses
a way to show how good his life is the
movie kind of asks the question if you'd
actually want to leave this life because
everything in it is keeping him from
danger it's very much an ad dilic Utopia
distant from crime where someone
basically has everything they need
however what Truman wants is some real
connections and we see as he remembers
what happened to his dad later on the
actor ends up returning and it's kind of
like the dead star in a so who comes
back 20 years later looking at you
Harold as Truman sits on the beach we
see as a lightning bolt strikes up the
sky slowing this down we can actually
see the bolt lights up the Moon too
which is something that wouldn't happen
in real life this hints that it's
actually fake and we later learn this is
where the command center is after doing
a rain dance Truman goes to Merill and
talks about how he wants them to go out
on an adventure whereas the trappings
have been fear induced before here we
see is they're kept as being Financial
burdens we have mortgage payments Truman
we have car payments what we're just
going to walk away from our financial
obligations all this stuff is something
that ends up holding you back and it's
also used as a way to keep Truman in
place he's unhappy at at his job unhappy
in his marriage but these burdens are
things that have stopped him from
leaving as Merl stands up we get a good
look at a dressing gown which we can see
is gray with white flowers on it later
on we see one of the old women viewers
rocking this too showing that this is an
item of clothing that the show sells cut
to some security guards you never see
anything anyway though I turn the camera
and play music
and know the wind blows in and the
curtains move and you don't see anything
this is a technique that they after news
in shows when showing a sex scene would
cause the writings to go up is it
ratings to go up get an x- rating anyway
and from here we could have the news
vendor and see a front page that's made
to keep them squarely on the island the
headline reads who needs Europe and
talks about an neurologist moving out to
sea Haven This Ss the idea that the
grass isn't Greener and they hope it'll
keep him locked in this place coming
face to face with his dad on the street
he's snatched by security and then
Truman stalled man's hit with joggers
and then a bus Escape apes taking him
away before Truman can ask questions
also I love how you can see the little
dog running off in the background who'd
just been held by the woman at the new
stand she was the one who grabbed
Truman's dad and obviously just put the
dog down so that she could go after him
now as Truman chases after it he's
stopped by a taxi and on an archway we
can read a Latin saying this says Unos
Pro Omnibus omnis Pro Uno which
translates to one for all all for one it
actually originates from The Three
Musketeers but in this film it has
another meaning all for one talks about
the town being built up for this one man
and one for all it's about how Truman
provides entertainment for all at this
point we C to Truman's mother and she
desperately tries to downplay the idea
he's just seen his dad still though he
looks through his old photos before it's
interrupted by Merl advertising more
stuff we really ought to throw out that
mower get one of those new elk
rotaries genuinely best moment in the
movie for me that just cracks me up
seeing Truman's reaction sitting with
Sylvia's sweater we and go back to where
they first met and see how Merl ended up
being forced upon him even when it comes
to love he didn't have a choice and his
entire life's been forced down this
Narrow Path at the dance we
hear this is actually a cover of T-Rex's
20th century boy however it's been
changed you can hear it a 50s rock song
and this is the further fit the
aesthetic of the show all the clouds of
civilians where have this generic 50
style to them and keep keeps things more
in line with what's seen as a more
wholesome time in America now in the
library Truman finally meets Lauren or
Silvia and we seees her face lights up
like she's talking to the most important
person in the world it's such a good
performance and you instantly see her
struggling to hold back and stanine with
the show whilst also following her heart
as they walk out we can also see a stand
of library books with what I counted to
be four atlases amongst them I'm
guessing these were putty so he could
discover the world through bucks instead
of him feeling like he actually had to
to go running off into the night this is
the first time he's truly free and he
can see why he'd obsess over the
feelings Sylvia brought to him she also
tries to tell him about the truth which
is when her quote unquote father shows
up scorting her off without raising the
alarm he tries to play it off that she's
crazy you're not the first you're not
the first she brings all her boyfriends
down here still though love at first
sight can't be defeated and this also
explains why Truman's desperate to move
to Fiji Fiji we're moving to Fiji Fiji
[Music]
we learned that he married Merill on the
rebound and since then he's longed to be
back with her in a way I also kind of
feel bad for Merill cuz she'd know that
he's in fact obsessed with this other
woman and the next day the radio goes
haywire and place a security feed
including him almost running over a
woman oh my God something
frequencies the radio DJ rattles of
about driver's safety and we also see a
reaction to his dad's appearance on a
newspaper we catch the headline talking
about cracking down on the homeless
adding a reason to why he got a scored
off in the top left we can also see its
number
10,765 which is roughly around 30 years
at the Truman bar we get a shot when we
cut to the TV and can also see that
there's a 30th Anniversary badge upon
the wall this dates Truman's age and
also gives us an idea of how long this
guy's been stuck in this prison for I
feel like the movie is sort of a
metaphor for a midlife crisis in which
someone wants to break free and do
something different we also see all the
actors repeating too including the guy
who walks in the Turn Style who popped
up earlier going off track Truman then
starts to suspect that he's actually in
the spotlight everything's inact but no
one can break character and the
background extras playing to this too we
can catch a guy walking around picking
up litter but if you look closely you'll
see that he's not actually grabbing
anything Truman then heads to a bench
and we cut to a couple who are played by
both Robert and Daryl Davis huge shout
outs to numerous lemon on redddit for
pointing out that these two actually
founded Seaside which is the location
they shot the movie at they agreed to it
being used as a set and as a thank you
they got to cameo in the movie by
catching a man from the new stand before
spying on him he basically goes
prototype Bruce Almighty and stops
traffic while stalls are running into a
building watching people get into an
elevator these are later shown to be
behind the scenes with the actors from
the other doors standing behind it
getting food this is something Marl
later has to cover for and the story is
the elevator malfunctioned as he's
thrown out we see the building is called
omnicron with the word potentially being
linked to omniscient huge shout outs to
wooden book on Reddit for that one and
it could hint to how Truman has an all
knowing presence around him running to
Marin store we then see the character
loading up a vending machine knowing he
has to look like he's doing something
you can see him taking out bars when
Truman has his back turned he then puts
them back in and it's all just done as
an act to make himself look busy about
the shop we can also see a woman with a
red and white hat and later on this is
an item that's shown to be something
viewers can buy going back to the beach
we then see m in selling how good that
life is look at that Sunset Truman it's
perfect now in reality it's impossible
for the moon to be as full as that in
front of the sun Marin also calls it the
big guy likely referring to it being
where his boss Kristoff is at big guy
spelled m o n and with his mother we
also see a photo album of some of his
early memories these include Truman
dressed as a clown and behind boss this
symbolically shows his Truman's a clown
who's solely alive to entertain and the
boss he's behind of the prison that he
lives in now this photo album that's
been brought out to make Truman think
he's actually left the island before
they do this by focusing on a picture of
Mount Rushmore but if you look closely
you'll see it's a crudely made set
Marilyn points to her bridesmaids and
says look Jean Jody Jo huge shout out to
Mike 23 pizo on Reddit for poting out
they're all nondescript brunettes whose
names start with a J this means that
Marl won't struggle to remember them and
can just rattle off names that begin
with a J putting on the TV we then see a
movie picked out especially for Truman a
hym of praise to small town life where
we learn that you don't have to leave
home to discover what the world's all
about though he slumps into a life of
acceptance again he quickly snaps out of
it when he catches a photo of Merl
Crossing her fingers The Jig Is up and
he realizes she wasn't doing it
sincerely and I think this is the
defining moment in the movie It's Al one
of the first things I remember figuring
out as a kid and maybe this one detail
sent me on the life of becoming a loser
sad anyway um wish me luck I'll cross my
fingers for
you could do a shot where we see how
quickly it turns from night to day
highlighting the sun itself is
controlled by Kristoff now due to them
living in a dome Truman's never actually
experienced natural sunlight thus he'd
have a vitamin D deficiency which we see
the make up for in the next shot this
appears as Truman sits and tunes his
radio and we can catch a massive tub of
it just to the left hand side now after
hearing Merl's story he follows her to
work where we see him going deep into
the set love how there's a group of
people in wheelchairs trying to stop him
and in orderly as well no one wants to
drop the ACT though and rather than
letting Truman know they have the
surgeon actor start now for here we cut
to a travel agent where we see a very
very big airplane risk poster and a
member of Staff with a tissue around
their neck typically this is something
actors have put on when makeup artists
are doing a their faces showing she's
just had it quickly done because he
arrived at the shop obviously they
really wouldn't have anyone ever working
this so yeah they've just quickly grab
someone off the street probably and be
like go go go go go now getting a bus to
Chicago we see the shock faces when he
first gets on and a kid points him out
the driver ends up stalling it and I
love how you can see sweat running down
his face as he apologizes to Truman
because he's just managed to stop him
sitting in his car Truman then points
out all the looping civilians showing
the surveillance system and Extras that
they have set up on the street as he
reverses out the car we see further
indoctrination in the state's model with
it simply saying it's a nice place to
live driving out with Merill you can
tell he's starting to go stir crazy and
I imagine you were just being stuck in
this prison now he just wants to go
wherever he can because he wants to get
out and doesn't care where it is blocked
by traffic this ends up clearing out
when it seems like they're heading home
getting to the bridge we see a sign in
the bottom right saying that you're now
leaving Sea Haven if you look closely at
the bottom you can also see it has a
line of text that says are you sure it's
a good idea forcing Merill to steer they
make it across where forest fire
warnings hint at what security measures
they have this is set up just before the
pair hit the nuclear plan which we can
see is having a meltdown it's clear that
Kristoff's pulling out all the stops to
make it seem convincing but after the
officer says thank you for your help
you're welcome J th he heads into the
forest but before getting caught you can
see that the trees there are planted in
Ros and lines this creates what looks
like a caror and it would obviously
never happen in nature showing that the
forest is artificial as for it in the
plants purpose I actually have an idea
and I think this part of the island has
its practical uses the trees would help
to provide oxygen inside the Dome and
the power PL could of course provide
power back home I also love the way the
cop on the left Axe and he's just
peering in trying to check Trum out you
have to realize that this would be like
seeing someone famous like Santa Claus
in real life but but to be fair I've
actually met him just just the way he
does his little hat tip too you can tell
his actor is trying his hardest and it's
so funny watching how the extras act
around him why don't you let me fix you
some of this new Mo cocoa drink all
natural cocoa beans from the upper
slopes of Mount Nicaragua no artificial
sweeteners what the hell are you talking
about who you talking to I've tasted
other Cocos this is the best this ad
being delivered by Merill while having a
clear breakdown just shows the demands
that people will have to stick with the
commercials now if you've been enjoying
us going back through these classic
movies and check out our classic movie
breakdown merch just below the video got
a bloody Terminator and Xenomorph ins
SPID design and all they all help videos
like this get made and me mean that I
won't have to go on a killing spree y
now Merl breaks character and then asks
for help before Marin sent in as a last
ditch attempt how could anyone expect me
to carry on under these conditions it's
unprofessional taking him to a bridge we
then get a line that shows how the
actors take holidays and vacations
remember that time I stayed up with you
all night in your tent cuz you wanted to
play North
Pole and I got
pneumonia you were at school for about a
month getting a peek behind the curtain
it's at this point that we see
Kristoff's feeding lines to Marin I love
how we have him saying that he'd never
lie to Truman while we see him putting
up a vade of being his best friend
really exemplifies how manipulative and
messed up this thing is and it's at this
point his father returns from the dead
he's the one who started this
existential crisis and thus the hope is
that getting him back will make Truman
remain in the fantasy now during this
bit we cut of the reactions of the world
including a Japanese family up on the
wall they have some pictures with text
in them which translates to the words
everyday Truman he's very much seen
almost like a religious figure and this
is shown in the love him protect him
t-shirts we see the security wearing
that's at this point that we see the
happiness that the creative team have
just suppos with Sylvia being Furious
she's seeing Truman stuck in this box
that represents the prison he's in and
over the top this is used to sell at
he's being completely exploited and not
seeing any of the money himself with
Truman basically being a slave that was
born into servitude C to Harry Shira
playing Mike Michaels and as we learn
he's about to interview Kristoff around
the world we see people getting ready
and can catch how much Truman's
integrated into other people's lives at
the bar there's a woman with a the top
with his face on and this is sort of in
an Andy warhole style you also see a
home with several collages and drawings
of him with characters hanging up on the
wall the girl has a meral doll and while
the baby cries away the mother ignores
it because she'd rather watch this guy
growing up on TV then watch your own
child a Kristoff appears like a god
looking over the city seeing all why
he's the perfect villain for this is
because he's very much the opposite of
Truman and whereas he knows nothing
Kristoff knows everything so also said
before we begin I'd like to thank you on
behalf of our audience for granting this
exclusive interview we know how
demanding your schedule is and we all
know how jealously you guard your
privacy showing that he realizes how
important privacy is yet benefits of
Truman's being exploited surrounding him
or countless TVs which is how he's able
to monitor all it gives the idea that he
can see absolutely everything and on top
of this his ability to control the Sun
and weather makes him a God throughout
his life we can see how people have
tried to infiltrate the set and at one
point catch a guy parachuting in telling
him he's on TV it's likely Sylvia was
involved in this as we can catch that
same sign up in her home you also to see
how they manufactured ways to keep him
on the island and in the end they
manipulated him to the point he'd have a
lifelong fear of water which is what
custom is Father there then we get one
of my favorite lines in the movie how do
you intend to explain his 22e
absence
Amnesia brilliant just playing up the
sub Trope of how they bring back de and
hearing this it always makes me laugh
yes I'm looking at you again Harold now
we learned Truman was adopted by the
corporation and the only reason he was
chosen because he was born on the due
date Kristoff promises that if Truman
truly wanted to escape that he would but
he says he prefers the cage as we know
though that isn't true man and we learn
that they're doing further things that
keep him in place this includes
introducing a brand new love interest in
having the world's first on air
conception having a child like this will
keep him further trapped in the prison
and the baby will probably be born into
this life as well he then watches Truman
sleeps with viewers also using him as a
way to comfort themselves to sleep too
bringing up the music Kristoff Strokes
the screen and we see the piano being
played by Philip Glass glass composed a
lot of the music in this film including
the piece that he plays here the next
day Truman does the astronaut bit but he
does this at the end to show that he
might be self-aware however it seems
like he's happy to be back in his own
loop with him going through a lot of
things that he did at the start we see
it as a new love interest interests
teased and everything looks like it's
going to be okay all there's clear
suspicion from the other people involved
and from here we C to Paul gamad sat
with a newspaper this is actually open
on the LA Times job listing page showing
that he was starting to look at other
places due to Truman getting suspicious
faking that he's as sleep in the
basement he does a sh shine to dig out
of his own prison which is when the town
goes in the high alert Marin sent over
and in front of the map of piji he then
realizes he's headed out showing that
this represents his dreams Maron break's
character and speaks directly to the
camera forcing Kristoff to C the
transmission for the very first time the
extras and cast Mount up and head out
and we see some of them like the travel
agent his neighbor the new girl at work
and also his parents the sun gets
brought up and everyone moves to first
position to try and start the day like
nothing's happened but Truman is gone
with him facing up to his fears and
heading out into the sea the body sails
on has the name Santa Maria which is
named after the one that belonged to
Christopher Columbus this is what he had
when he went to the new world signifying
his travel out into a new one we see as
they send the cast out after him with a
bus driver being unable to drive the
boat because he's an actor left with
nothing else the weather programs in
Access which localizes the storm
directly over the boat it's such a good
way to test the character you know he
went through this when he was younger
and in the end it shows what he's really
made of people around the world unite
behind him because he's what they love
not the show itself and it reveals the
monster that Kristoff really is he's
happy to kill Truman if he has to
because he wants his complete control
over his life either way we know the
show is going to end but he'd rather him
die than have him leave because he has
control over this it's classic coercive
Behavior but Truman survives it and
comes out on top which is when Kristoff
realizes that he has to let him go now I
love the literal fourth wall breaking
moment is Truman hits the edge of the
Dome and we see that the sky is in fact
fake going up the stairs Kristoff
finally speaks to him sounding like he
is the voice of God the stairs himself
sort of look like a Stairway to Heaven
and outside will be the life he gets
after his life here he tells him the
truth but also tries to get him to stain
the World by promising him alive that's
without fear he struges the screen and
pleads that he stays and in the end
wants him to remain in the show asking
him to respond we then get the perfect
line to end the film with in case I
don't see you
good afternoon good evening and good
night get me every single time now what
makes this line so incredible is that
Kristoff expects some big rousing speech
or to stay behind and remain with them
in the fake World rather than giving in
though and doing something that's going
to give Kristoff what he wants or the
perfect ending he just drops a dumb
catchphrase and robs Kristoff of getting
that final thing all Kristoff wants to
do is broadcast the big moments in his
life but him just doing this it just
shuts the entire thing down now it also
works as its own quable too and in a way
it's the best Fu possible it's genuinely
the perfect way to close out the film
and I can't think of a better way that
they could have ended it we close out
with people deciding to watch something
else and it sums of how shallow reality
TV is obviously this even predicted that
before the Boom in the industry and it's
hard to deny how much the Tran show got
these things right it's easily one of
the best films from the past 25 years
and it took Jim Carrey away from from
being a comedic actor into a completely
new Direction when I think back on his
career this is one of the best
performances for me and it went several
awards for a damn good reason I still
think it was pretty underrated at the
time though but it's picked up a major
following since its release I really
hope you've enjoyed us going back
through these films and hopefully you've
got some new stuff to appreciate when
you go back and check it out huge thank
you for checking out the breakdown and
make sure you subscribe for more classic
movie breakdowns we have been releasing
these videos early for members so if you
want to check them out before anyone
else then please click the join button
cost 99 cents a month makes a big
difference to the channel and you'll get
not only audio only versions were very
very early but also the edits too uh so
yeah thank you everyone who's done that
now our next video it is going to be
Apocalypse Now and Mt is also working on
a Spider-Man breakdown as well lots of
things coming out down the line I hope
to see you over there and yeah thank you
for all the support you know I love
doing these videos so much and I really
appreciate that you guys of them too so
out the way thank you so much and if I
don't see you again good afternoon good
evening and good night peace